[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
علاقه الانسان بصفحه السماء ومحتوياتها
علاقه ازليه فالانسان القديم كان يعتقد ان
حركه الاجرام السماويه لها تاثير على
سلوكيات الخليقه والحوادث الكونيه
والارضيه وبالغ بها فنشا علم التنجيم ومع
الدراسه لاحوال شروقها وتوسطها وغروبها
وضعوا لها قواعد فنشا علم الفلك فعلم
الفلك ولد من رحم التنجيم قال المنجم
والطبيب كلاهما لا تحشر الاجساد قلت
اليكما طهرت ثوبيا للصلاه وقبله طهرا فاين
طهر من
جسديكما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والقبه السماويه تتكون من نجوم منفرده
ومجاميع تخيلها الانسان القديم على هيئه
جمادات وحيوانات وحتى البشر ونسج حولها
الاساطير اسماها العرب القدماء بالبروج
لعلوها وجمالها ولقد جعلنا في السماء
بروجا وزيناها
للناظرين
[موسيقى]